hey guys today I'm going to talk about
fate of the most fearsome man in the
Seven Kingdoms about fate of the man
called the mountain that rides or often
just simply the mountain in this video
you will be introduced with troll that
the head of house could gain is going to
play in the new red wedding that we are
going to have in the upcoming season a
few months ago I brought your theory of
mind a theory in which we are going to
have a new red wedding in season 7 aka
the gold wedding confirm the lines
between Cersei and your Greyjoy death
little by this theory also be sealed
with marriage between those two main
villains ever since I brought you this
theory imaging evil on sources and
Europe's first wedding night killed both
of them with someone else's help of
course you've been asking me what about
the mountain coggle Jaime managed to
pass by searched his personal and most
trusted guard first off if you are not
introduced with the gold wedding Theory
I'm recommending you to watch it first
and then come back to watch this video
however let's get back to the mountains
role that he is going to play that night
of course the Jaime most likely wouldn't
be able to pass by Sir Gregor Clegane
he might would have been able to kill
him with his right hand
but now let's face it he wouldn't stand
a chance against the mountain who's near
death only made him stronger
so yeah answer on your question about
how Jaime is going to pass by surcease
most trusted guard is simply he won't
you might be confused now and you might
also wonder does it mean that Jaime
won't kill Cersei and urine does that
mean that one of the most viewed videos
so mine won't come true no it does not
mean that I still believe that Jaime
will in the very end of season 7 kill
his once beloved sister and lover
Cersei along with her new husband yearn
whereupon she is going to lead Lannister
army to the north to unite his forces
with all other armies to increase
chances for the living side in a great
war that is coming the mountains rolled
at wedding night might and by the cereal
be helping Jamie to pass by Queen's
Guard and to enter the room in addition
he might even help Jaime to kill vicious
urine it would confirm a theory that
Qyburn has been working for ver this
whole time would confirm a theory that
I've shared with you a few months ago as
you all know I never expressed a theory
and just expected from you guys to
believe in it I'm always bringing some
kind of proof that my conformity
that I'm introducing you with I've
already brought you a 10 minute long
video in which I provided all possible
pros they're going favor to this theory
image Qyburn is this whole time working
for various a theory in which the
mountain is going to help Jamie as it's
going to be Qyburn sorter so feel free
to check it out in this video I'm only
going to show you the most trusted or
should I say the most obvious proofs
along with a few files that are
supporting already mentioned theory from
the very beginning since the very first
episode Qyburn appeared on the show
they're raising more and more yet
unexplained and unanswered questions for
an example why did Qyburn even decide to
save the mountains life life of the same
man that almost killed him at Harrenhal
and how Qyburn has been able to use spy
capabilities of same little birds
debtor's has used in previous seasons
same little birds that very centurions
concerns about their loyalty replied
with man can be fickle but birds I
always trust we all know that various
cannot be fooled that easily
additionally Varys is known as the man
of knowledge and whisperers as a man
that knows every step of every living
man in the Seven Kingdoms which means
that if very slowly trust someone that
someone won't betray him even if that
would mean that that for that someone
which is not a possible outcome but
rather of fact Varys won't be ever
betrayed by someone he fully trusts as
we all know Qyburn and Cersei became
extremely close considering the fact
that sir situated people around or
especially the just ride ones with
paranoia and suspicious thoughts while
Qyburn gained sources full trust by
bringing sir gregor clegane back to life
after he was seriously wounded by spear
coded in Manticore venom during his
fight against Oberyn Martell after which
Cersei named Qyburn as a master of
whisperers as a varus's replacement in a
small Council even if Qyburn managed to
let's call as bribe few varys's little
birds and even if those few spice agree
to betray varies there is no way that
various would and find it out there is
no way that none of them wouldn't send
whisper to Varys this is also raising a
few important questions and you're
probably wondering if Qyburn and little
birds are loyal to Ares
why does little birds inform Qyburn
about the Wildfire
who later informed
circe about it which led to annihilation
of the great Sept of Baelor along with
mace Tyrell Margaery Tyrell Loras Tyrell
high Sparrow and Oh little sparrows
before I give you an answer on that
question let me just highlight one fact
that you all have to know before we go
any further
Varys has been loyal to House Targaryen
all the time
Varys has been working on a plan to
bring to Daenerys and House Targaryen
back the Iron Throne that has been taken
from them since the fall of House
Targaryen here we come to the answering
a question which was if Qyburn and
albert's are loyal to Aerys why did
little birds inform Qyburn about the
Wildfire who later informed Cersei the
answer that question is actually pretty
simple search his plan to destroy the
great Sept of Baelor along video all
important people in it mesh perfectly
with vs. plan
additionally in my opinion very sexual
commanded Qyburn images little birds to
find out is wildfire is really under the
great Sept of Baelor and if it really is
to inform Cersei about it immediately
Varys is a smart man he was aware that
if Cersei wipes out most of the
leadership with wildfire it would lead
her losing her allies which in effect
exactly happened and is very probably
expected it gave him an opportunity to
make new allies in this case with Olenna
Tyrell who now only wants to mentor son
her nephew and her knees by the exact
verse manage to provide a new ally for
his queen and made the nurses take over
even easier also the fact that Chiron
brought sir gregor clegane back to life
go back in third season almost Gilliam
is something that I can get over it
would only make sense if it's part of a
bigger plan of vengeance it could be
that Qyburn created a monster only to
get even closer to Cersei which would
allow them when the time comes to easily
kill Cersei while she thinks that he is
her most trusted protector as she thinks
he is ever since the mountain she has
been brought back to life as the
mountain vulture closes then the only
guard throughout season six he will
continue to be in the upcoming season as
well as lake forward as are confirming
the ones which were taken in Dubrovnik
if the theory comes true it would only
prove once again how brilliant mind of
Varys is which would once again confirm
versus high intelligence and cunning
skills Oh
so if the spheric I'm sure it would only
confirm a theory of mine in which Jamie
is going to kill sir cm urine in season
seven finale which he might do with
mountains help or a child at the
mountain could simply let Jamie to enter
the romance kill two biggest villains
whereupon Jamie is going to join a great
war with Lannister forces forces that
the living side desperately needs [ __ ]
that fell among a few others be crucial
for Jamie to finally understand who he
is once the load lover and sister really
is which will result to Jamie killing
once again the one whom he was supposed
to protect but also will once again save
a lot of innocent lives if you say by
killing the Mad King it's most likely
true that we are going to see only few
scenes of sir Gregor Clegane the
upcoming season but though still could
be one of the most important scenes that
we are going to see might be the scenes
that will take Circe's reign to an early
end a few scenes that could be of the
greatest importance for the leaning side
as sources that would allow Jamie to
support all inside by leading the
Lannister army to the north in
conclusion not only that this theory
goes in favor to the whole Jamie's life
story but it would also represent
arguably the greatest waste in Game of
Thrones series even greater than
Bolton's and phrase betrayal over stars
Cersei would be we can't even call it
betrayed by her three most trusted
people would be killed by her brother
like her most trusted adviser and by her
most trusted guard we all already
started loving Jaime ever since he
revealed the truth to Brienne the truth
about his what's called betrayal over
his king betrayal that saved thousands
of innocent lives which coming Cersei
and allowing to the Lynx eyes focus saw
their sources and intentions to the
great war that is coming would also love
Jaime to finally show his good side not
only the dispute is going favor to the
whole Jaime story not only that it would
be one of the greatest twists and Game
of Thrones series but it also seems like
something that showrunners would pull
out to leave us that elemental
speechless in season finale in following
days I'm also going to make a video
about Clegane ball that in my opinion
will take place in the final eight
season if a few of us thought that the
mountain with one good Act which
allowing Jaime to kill Cersei would be
is enough for his brother sin Oracle
gain and eventually for us too
him all his sins that's definitely not
going to happen
sir gregor clegane has done more than a
few terrible things throughout his life
which he started doing since he was a
child he held his own brother's head in
a burning brazier only because his
younger brother played with the toy that
he discarded as he was growing he was
killing more and more innocent people
was raiding more and more villages only
to later be knighted by prince rhaegar
targaryen this honorable man that the
mountain is whom always lacked honor
only money or path since he was knighted
by Prince Rhaegar and still he obeyed
commands to kill the same princess two
children during Robert's rebellion upon
killing regards daughter and his baby
son the mountain then proceeded to
brutal rape records wife Elia very
particular the head of house Cogan is
infamously dishonorable man and even if
he is going to help Jani he still
deserves to die and the best way to see
the mountains that would be include
gamble which we might see in the
upcoming seasons and as always don't
forget to leave your thoughts about all
of this in the comment section down
below so yeah hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]